it's almost the end of January 2020
right now and all the bargains are
completely gone so I thought what I do
for you guys today is actually try find
the best deal on the Microsoft Surface
laptop three what's going on guys my
name is David homage and welcome back to
the channel if you're new here thank you
so much for joining me if you don't know
anything about me again my name is David
Thomas I'm a masters of architecture
graduate and I'm also an e-commerce
entrepreneur I've run many e-commerce
stores in the past with some of them
going global in a matter of years so if
you want to learn anything about
e-commerce is a free guide in the
description below check it out if that's
something that interests you anyway
moving on to our main topic of
discussion today which is the best price
you can get for the Microsoft Surface
laptop 3 now I did an almost I guess
first world country search for this one
if you want to put it that way I
searched all of the major Australian
stores and also all of the major US
stores to try find the best deal for you
guys out there right now we're gonna be
talking about the surface laptop 3i 5
128 gigabyte model so the bottom of the
range the cheapest of the cheap I
started my search off and JB hi-fi which
is the top premium tech retailer in
Australia I guess if you want to call
them this is where I personally go to
purchase all my tech firm from de dot
because they usually have the best deals
but to my surprise this time around they
had no surface laptop threes of the i5
model whatsoever they started at a much
higher price point of 2000 plus
Australian so we completely scrapped
that one and took it out of the equation
next up is Harvey Norman which is again
an Australian retailer moving on to
Harvey Norman which is another
Australian retailer these guys usually
have the premium price tag and not the
premium products however to my surprise
I did find a surface laptop 3 for 1699
Australian or 11:49 us that's actually
quite high if we're being honest here
because I know we can get it for a lot
cheaper than that so Kogan another
Australian brand 1749 or I think it was
1179 us so more expensive than Harvey
Norman again which isn't a good thing we
want to make sure we can get it as cheap
as possible so I had that thought to
myself cheap nasty where can we get some
cheap and nasty products so I took a
look at eBay and found absolutely
nothing and then I took a look at
Facebook marketplace around my location
and again found absolutely nothing so
not very good start here whatsoever
we're paying a very premium price tag
for I guess the premium product so it
could be argued but I want the best deal
today but usually when I buy all my
camera gear either buy it from camera
house or Toby's deals toby was
advertising a massive 30 percent off
sale I think they were kind of getting
us with some ecommerce tricks here
because they were saying 1379 down from
18-49 or something ridiculous so
straight away we've come in at a much
much cheaper price at 1379 also thanks
to the aid of the Google Shopping app
and the honey app we were able to bring
it down to 13 49 which is equivalent to
nine hundred and ten US dollars so for
nine hundred and ten US dollars we've
found ourselves a pretty premium laptop
and not a premium price tag I thought
this is a pretty good deal but I thought
we could do better moving outside of
Australia because America usually has
much better prices than US and sometimes
the shipping is completely free to
Australia so it doesn't take it out of
my search equations usually thinking
photography company doing really good
deals I moved to BH video and photo
looked at their website and fortunately
didn't find the best results BH had it
for 14 35 or about 980 US dollars so a
little bit more expensive than Toby's
deals but not too much more expensive if
you're actually are shipping it within
the US and get free shipping whereas if
we were to ship it to Australia behan H
wouldn't give us free shipping it cost a
little bit more than that price today
there then I moved on to Best Buy
because I know heaps of you guys have
commented in my videos
for previously saying they've got some
amazing deals from Best Buy
getting it at ridiculous sub 900 numbers
during Christmas sales during Black
Friday sales which is absolutely amazing
so I thought I'd check out Best Buy
first Best Buy came in at about fourteen
hundred and eighty Australian dollars or
999 u.s. so you can still get it under a
thousand bucks at Best Buy which again
not too bad of a deal but that's your
everyday price that isn't really a good
deal whatsoever moved on to Walmart here
thinking again a major chain retailer
unfortunately 1566 Australian or I think
it was 50/50 nine us or just 999 us for
the alternative option that they kind of
secretly try to push you away from I'm
not sure what Walmart's game plan is
here but I guess that enticed me to
click on it added to cart find out what
kind of price they were really trying to
get me with even though the one next to
it was a lot cheaper from the get-go and
finally I thought what about the actual
Microsoft Store I know you can get a 10%
discount off the Microsoft Store for
being an eligible student so I went on
the Microsoft Store and actually to my
surprise I found it for 1359 clean no
discounts whatsoever so in the back of
my head I'm already thinking sweet
13:59 take 10% we get another about 135
bucks off well I did sign in with a
student email account which is still
thankfully eligible for a student
discount
but that surface laptop 3 is not
eligible for the student discount it's
only all the premium ones above that so
in the Microsoft Store you get it for
thirteen fifty nine or nine hundred and
sixteen dollars USD so at the end of the
day the best deal I could find was
Toby's deals in Australia for thirteen
hundred and forty nine Australian
dollars or nine hundred and ten US
depending on the Australian dollar and
how the US currency exchange works you
can probably get it for a lot less and
little
under 900 if you're lucky so that's all
I have for you guys today thank you so
much for watching I hope I was able to
find you guys a good deal and hopefully
you're going to be able to score
yourself a brand new surface laptop
three to start 2020 the right way